you do realize that if you are smaller than extra small
you can still fit into the extra small
like it might be a little bit loose on you
slightly unflattering but it's not the same thing
has been larger than the largest size
if you can't fit into an XL or XXL (in typical straight size retailers)
whatever you're done
like you physically could not get the item of clothing onto your body
there's no amount of like
altering that's gonna make it fit you
if it doesn't fit you doesn't fit you
that is like in no way shape or form the same thing as like
skinny people not being able to fit into a size xs
an item of clothing being too baggy for you
is not the same as it not literally being able to go over your body
67% of women in the United States or more are plus size
if I'm not mistaken
roughly like 19% of the fashion industry caters to plus size women
do you do you see
I don't I know math might be hard
but I'm gonna trust your ability to understand that there's an issue there
I don't know why people are on Twitter arguing with me about this before 9:00am
I'm going back to bed and I pray that when I wake up
y'all have developed a little bit of common sense thank you